a woman met a guy who's five foot nine
at the party and brilliant and funny and
handsome she's not gonna notice these
five foot nine but when it comes down to
putting a number on a screening function
on a dating app people start treating
dating like shopping
john berger welcome to the show
chris thanks for having me on the
podcast talk to me about how you ended
up as an authority on the dating market
well authority may be a bit strong but
but yeah this is the first question i
typically get which is basically how the
heck did a
a business journalist a writer for
fortune magazine ever end up
writing a book about dating and the
answer is basically the it actually has
a lot to do with with my years at
fortune magazine the editorial staff at
fortune was more women than men
but it was one of these things where i
couldn't help but notice that most of
the men and fortune were either married
like myself
or involved in long-term relationships
whereas the women especially the ones i
seem to know best and i was friends with
they were disproportionately single
and they weren't just single they had
all these dating horror stories and
dating histories that that made no sense
to me especially since from my
perspective a lot of them seem to have
way more going for them dating wise than
we guys did um so the origin of my first
book datanomics was basically just
trying to explain
how we got to a world in which dating
had become so much easier for men than
for women
what was the summary of what you found
out during that research
so
initially i thought this had something
to do with the job markets in
in these really cosmopolitan cities like
new york or london or
toronto la like i thought there was
something about
the the industries the job markets in
these cities that was drawing
more women particularly college educated
women
to these cities than
than men
and
that was that was my premise for
datanomics but it turns out i was wrong
that this is not a
a big city versus small-town problem
this is an everywhere issue so basically
in every western country and in many
non-western countries as well
over the past 20 30 years we've had
about
one-third more women than men
graduate from college or graduate from
from uni as you
may call it you know overseas um
uh and as a result you end up with a
dating pool after college that has
you know one-third more women than men
and now obviously this wouldn't matter
at all if we were more open-minded about
whom we date and eventually marry
but at the same time
that
that
that this higher education
gender imbalance has become wider and
wider
there's been a simultaneous increase in
what academics referred to
as assortative mating which is just a
fancy way of saying that
university grads tend to want to date
and marry other university grads what do
you think is the root of the assortative
mating increase
i i think a lot of it just is
familiarity i mean people tend to
date an event and marry
people who we come in contact with um
and i think you know 30 40 years ago i
think there were more like the
communities we lived in were more mixed
when it came to socioeconomics um and
you might go to a church or
a social club with people of more varied
backgrounds but i think
because of kind of
some of the social stratification we've
seen because of economic changes i i
feel like
i could be wrong about this but but my
my answer my theory on your question is
that um
university grads and non-university
grads don't rub elbows in the same way
they once did
40 years ago and i think that's kind of
the root the root cause of it but i mean
i
a big theme of both datanomics and my
new book make your move is encouraging
people to get past this and to be
open-minded about dating people
you know
you know with different educational
backgrounds because i think that's the
key to solving this problem with the sex
ratio hypothesis and i've read a bunch
of different studies including i think
the original seminal one that was done
on it
is a hell of an effect you know you see
really really bizarre changes in
the way that people respond to their
local ecology so there's this sentence
in the study where it says it's almost
as if human mating strategy responds to
its local ecology like a plant or
something right that you adapt the way
that you go about finding and refining
your potential partner pool based on the
relative number of men and women and
what your sex is as well so if you are a
guy and you have a surplus of other men
you have to play the game so to speak
that women want which tends to be more
dates before first sex it means that you
end up with less casual sex you have
higher rates of virginity blah blah blah
reverse that when you have a surplus of
women and the scarcity of men you have
more casual sex you have fewer dates
before sex and i think you have an
increase in sexual violence as well when
you have a scarcity of men and an
increase of women but
the bottom line is that it's it's a very
strange impact across both
yeah yeah the scare you know in terms of
the sexual violence one of the things i
i
i discovered when researching the first
book datanomics was i i spent some time
looking at at uh trends in china where
you kind of see the opposite where
because of the old one the one child
policy in china
you have a group of marriage age people
where the overall population
is more male than female
and
what's interesting is that as the
as the youth population skewed more and
more mail
various levels of criminality increased
you know
burglary murder things like that the
only category of major crime that
declined
as the population became more male
was was sexual assault
and the theory
um
the theory put forth by the author of
the study was you know it's kind of
crass but she argued that as um
when women are more scarce
men value them more
um and are more protective of them
even if they're not in a relationship i
don't think that they have a chance at
being in a relationship with them yeah i
i i you know i think this is more of a
when in rome thing than people making
conscious decisions about how to
behave
based on a head count i just think that
the the
the the culture as you alluded to the
culture changes depending upon these
these prevailing sex ratios and what's
interesting is that most of the
the sex racial sex ratio research that
you alluded to that that
has been
you know come out over the past 20 30 40
years
it it kind of evolved from research on
other species
and in other in other mammals other
primates
you see similar things that when
you have imbalances
in the sex ratio among the mating
population you get the same sort of
behavioral changes
that we've observed when it comes to
human mating and human dating well one
of the things that's interesting about
the china study there is the increase in
anti-social behavior and
violent and non-violent crimes amongst
men because this is something else that
you learn as soon as a man gets into a
relationship his testosterone drops and
then when a man has children his
testosterone drops again
why well it's because if you are
potentially going to father a child or
you're now the father of a child going
out and doing something reckless or
getting into a fight you don't need to
do that anymore it's way way way too
much of a risk so it's much smarter for
you to down regulate that testosterone
to be a more
careful parent to not get angry at the
fact that your child won't stop crying
or whatever it might be um but this is
one of the dangerous things you know
these imbalances in the in the sexual
marketplace are leading to an underclass
of sexless men which can
create quite a dangerous foundation for
you to then
sit society on top of
i i agree with everything you said but
what's what's for me extra interesting
about this is the this um what you just
described about putting men into
competitive situations and suddenly
their testosterone levels rise and you
get more anti-social behavior it's
actually not just men
that that when
when you put women into competitive
situations their testosterone levels
rise too and if you read hannah rosen's
book the end of men she has a whole
section all about rising criminality
rates among women
and and how
uh putting women into increasingly
competitive situations has has has led
to a rise in female criminality
no way
yeah it's it's fascinating so so i so a
lot of these things that we like to say
you know it's a guy thing or a girl
thing it's actually a human thing and
and i'm i'm always trying to kind of
pull it back to say you know what
you know this is about us as humans not
necessarily about
you as a woman me as a man etc do cities
make this worse then did you find that
the research coming out of cities
further amplified these problems
i mean i i thought that was going to be
the case because i i've lived in new
york city for a long time and i've heard
my female friends have all these dating
horror stories but i'm not sure it's
actually true i mean the
the imbalance at least in the us is
actually greater
in rural states like west virginia than
it is in manhattan
um
so i'm i'm and i've interviewed you know
lots of
matchmakers in
less populous parts of the country um
where
they've told me stories that sound very
similar to what i've heard from people
in new york city so i i
i i assumed
i assumed that the city situation would
be worse i'm just not sure it actually
is what was the response like from women
and men when you did your
post book tour and you were talking
about datanomics
i mean i mean with datanomics i think
for
the women who showed up at my
lectures book events i i think it was
kind of a sense of relief that finally
like
they knew there was something really
messed up in the dating market
and
all their married friends and their
mothers and their grandmothers and their
aunts kept telling them that they must
be doing something wrong
and i think for a lot of them just
hearing that this is actually
a statistical problem a behavioral
problem
provided some sense of relief that
wasn't their fault
um
but i will say
i like i
i didn't envision dynamics as an advice
book at all it was kind of more pop
science
um i had a really snooty attitude
towards the whole self-help genre i
think because i came from this you know
serious journalism background writing
for fortune um
but when i got out on book tour with
datanomics
while women yes were relieved to hear
that there was this bigger problem that
wasn't their fault and explained some of
their experiences
they still wanted me to tell them what
to do about it and i didn't i didn't
really have any great answers for them
then and that's kind of what led to the
the second book what did men say after
datonomics
well
you may not be so shocked to hear this
but men don't usually buy dating books
men actually don't buy self-help books
in general
so yeah i did get some feedback from men
and
if you
google my name and like on some of the
reddit boards that deal with the red
pill crowd
um to me like from what i read it kind
of sort of verified what they believed
about
um
the competitive nature of
of
relations between the sexes but i
i wasn't really writing for men i mean i
think this is a this is a
a problem that exists for women and the
reason i wrote the book is because
i didn't understand and my wife didn't
understand what why we had all these
single female friends who had everything
going for them but couldn't seem to find
a decent guy okay so
that's datanomics which is basically
you've you've created a problem for
yourself you've identified that there is
an issue in the sexual marketplace but
there's an open loop on the end of this
which is
and what do we do about it and that's
where the next one comes in
yeah i mean in in hindsight it was
probably cruel of me to write a whole
book oh get two books get two books out
of it john don't give people every all
of the [ __ ] answers in one no no you
know chris you're you're right from that
point of view but i will say my
my editor for datanomics a a brilliant
woman named maisie tipton she she kept
telling me that i needed more solutions
and more hope
in the book
and i kept ignoring her because again i
had the snooty attitude towards the
genre and the last thing in the world i
wanted to do was become the love doctor
well let me give you let me just
interject that because i'm having a
conversation at the moment with a couple
of different publishers and one of the
potential things that i would be
interested in writing about is this
imbalance in the dating market i think
it's fascinating i think it's relevant i
think that it has existential
consequences for society right
one of the
very rough outlines that i sent over to
a very very good well-known publisher
they came back and said something along
the lines of um we would need it to be
much more light-hearted because this
doesn't sound like a tremendously
uplifting book they put in bold letters
at the bottom must uplift the reader i'm
like well
to be honest no you're right
no i it's not massively uplifting
so
in this genre if you're going to write a
self-help book there has to be hope it
has to be uplifting this is something i
heard a lot so i'm not the least bit
surprised that
that um
and if you look at the at the self-help
books that sell well
they always are are positive and they
have solutions
in that that book i referenced before
the end of men by hannah rosen
um it's a brilliant book but i don't
think it's sold pretty you know terribly
well yeah well i can already tell from
the title yeah the title the title
itself is is kind of dark right
um
and
honestly the datanomics was not my
preferred title for datanomics what
would you have
i want to call it the man deficit
yes yeah because you that's one of the
chapters right right right
but but i was getting the same feedback
you got that's that's that's depressing
that's dark it has not uplifting enough
um
but for me it kind of
you know i
i mean these folks know way more about
selling books than you and i do so i'm
not i'm not arguing against their
you know their knowledge but to me the
man deficit was more what the book was
going to be about
but
what's the point in writing the book
nobody's gonna read it so um
so i i i get where they're coming from
and i do think
i mean honestly i mean one of my i think
in hindsight one of my
i don't know if it was a problem or
maybe i didn't emphasize it enough with
datanomics was that i was way more
interested
in solving the boy problem in education
than i was in solving the dating problem
for women
well that's two two solutions to the
same problem right typically women are
dating hypergamously as you have an
increased number of women that are
within a educated or highly educated
field they compete themselves out of
their own dating pool because there are
ever fewer and fewer men that are above
and across from where those women are so
there are two solutions that you can
either get women to
change the way that they're aiming or
you can begin to bring the water line of
men up
right but but as you can imagine the
there probably isn't a huge market for
books on education policy uh yeah
i don't know if you if you read the
economics but the last chapter is is
highly um
focused on on how we solve the boy
problem in education and also
trying to provide some advice to
to young people applying to college and
to their parents or your university as
you make refer to it in the uk um just
letting them know that the the the
prevailing sex ratios on college
campuses have a huge impact on the
campus culture particularly when it
comes to dating
um i don't know if you want to get into
that a little bit but but but to me i
think
actually getting back to your first
question that were your prior question
this this was a
a big reaction of the book that that
particularly
young people who had just graduated from
college or parents of college or
university applicants were telling me
how shocked they were by some of the
anecdotes and some of the research and
datanomics showing how
prevailing sex ratios on a college
campus can have a huge impact on on the
way
kids on campus view dating how so
so in datanomics i did a an analysis of
about 40 major
public and private universities and i
ranked them by their their sex ratios
and i paired that ranking with
students own descriptions of what dating
life is like on these college campuses
and the descriptions came courtesy of
the college prowler
you know college review book it's
basically a book written for applicants
you know so if you want to know what the
um
you know what the
engineering program is like at
university of georgia or what the
cafeteria food is like or in this case
what what the dating life is like there
you can read you can read it's all
written by current or recent students so
you can get a sense of what what life is
like you know on these college campuses
and it was really it was
it was really striking how differently
kids talked about dating
at various schools depending upon the
the prevailing sex ratios and i'll give
you some examples here
so rensselaer polytechnic institute
which is kind of a science and
engineering school in upstate new york
rpi
um
rpi is
about 70 percent men 30 percent women to
you know more than two men for every one
woman
and
here's what students said about dating
at rpi
more people are involved in
relationships girls seem to become stuck
up because they're in such a minority
that they can afford to be choosy
um
caltech which is you know california
institute of technology in california
and if and if you remind me i have an i
have a funny story about caltech which i
can add at the end um caltech is 60 40
60 men 40 women three women for every
two three men for every two women
uh here's what students said there about
dating
students here tend not to date that have
relationships breakups are rare and many
couples get married after caltech
um even the schools that were 50 50 it
was kind of a more it was more familiar
to me as a 50 year old guy when it came
to like what i remember about college so
tufts university which is in suburban
boston
tufts is 50 50. halfway through
sophomore year people begin to pair off
and generally stay paired off through
junior and senior year
that's that was that's familiar to me
that's what i remember
um
university of miami which has a rep a
reputation as a big party school but it
also happens to be 50 50. and here's
what um
what students say about dating there
random hookups are common in the
beginning but after a few months or a
year relationships take over
so compare that the schools that are
either more men than women or 50 50 to
some of the schools that are
disproportionately female
i'll start with new york new york
university in new york city
and nyu is 61 percent
female 39 male again three
is that that's about representative
typically
i think on average for most colleges now
it wasn't when i wrote them it was more
like
75 35 i must say not 75. it was more
like um
i'm sorry it was it was closer to 58
30
uh 42 yeah and i wrote them but when
1957 by 2013
but but now it's yep
i think this year's graduating class i
think you're right i think at least in
the u.s it's 60 40. it's going to be
bang on so so
yeah so nyu new york university here's
what what kids say about dating at nyu
guys take advantage of the male to
female ratio and most have no plans of
settling into a long-term relationship
um
boston university where actually my son
is a senior
bu is 62 percent
uh
female 38 male
here's the comment
freshman year is a sexual explosion
there are girls to go around and around
again
and lastly sarah lawrence college which
used to be an all-girls school in in
suburban new york it's now co-ed but
it's 75 female
25 male
3 women for every one man
you could probably guess what i'm about
to read to you but i'll you know let me
share
quote the girls complain about
loneliness the guys get more than they
can handle and mindless one-night stands
are rampant
so so for me like doing the doing the
college research really kind of showed
how these prevailing sex ratios don't
just affect the statistical odds of
getting into a relationship but they
change culture they change behavior as
well yeah and rolling the clock forward
the people that graduate from those
colleges presuming that men and women
drop out at similar rates i think men
might drop out a little bit more than
women literally but probably not enough
to rebalance this uh sex ratio that
we've got and i think that
yeah you'd be about right it's saying 60
40 women to men but by 2030 the
projection is two-thirds women to
one-third men at a four-year us college
so this trend is going to continue to
get more and more pronounced
yep yeah no i mean i
i i
as i said with my first book i you know
part of my
purpose in writing it was was reversing
that trend and trying to figure out how
we get more
more men to attend university or college
um
but that's kind of a that's a long-term
thing it's not going to solve the dating
problem in the short term well the other
thing is that dating is inherently an
individual
act right dating your your dating
strategy what sort of partner you're
looking for how you're going about
looking for a partner that's something
that you can impact individually what
you're trying to do or what you would be
trying to do there by continuing to
improve men's desire to go to college
that's systemic right that's completely
that's a big broad social change that
you're trying to get to do yes it
happens individually one by one by one
but i feel like trying to impact
individuals dating strategies
is a simpler problem than trying to
improve an entire sexes view of how to
go to college no no you're right but i
guess from my point of view the boy
problem in education isn't just a dating
problem oh yeah men don't just go to
college to get laid yeah although your
son your son did choose one of the uh
colleges that's got a
female ratio so so my son is actually
gay so he gets oh god he's ruined it
i i know i know why didn't you go to the
one with the technology college you're
75 men because because i
um
believe it or not prevailing sex ratios
have no impact on same-sex dating
because you can always divide by two the
rules are just thrown out of the window
but but i will say my my son
my gay my son alex says he has lots of
wonderful female friends um
um
but yeah he gets no benefit from the
the oversupply of fabulous women at bu
bloody hell okay so getting on to make
your move what are the mistakes
that men make that you're trying to get
women to avoid making
well i so i the book is really written
for women uh because that's who buys
dating books and
you know there are two big themes of
make your move um the first one is
basically encouraging women
to be more assertive to make the first
move with men
because and we can get into this i
believe that that research shows there
are
lots of advantages to doing so and it's
going to be easier to
find your true love so to speak if you
don't wait and wait for him to find you
and the second big theme of make your
move and i think this has been a little
bit more controversial but i'm happy to
to make my arguments is encouraging
people to get off the dating apps
because i i don't
i
don't think online dating
has been good for
for relationships for romance and i
think it's only going to get worse
talk to me about how you think the metoo
movement impacted dating
i so i i
i look at it from
the standpoint of of women and
yeah like i'm not i mean i think in
general i think the me too movement has
been good for
for dating and good for men because
it's clearer now
there was a lot of gray area behavior
before me too which meant i think
unfortunately thought was okay but never
really was okay and and
me probably like lots of other men i'm
you know
after the me too meant launched i i
spent some time thinking back about
experiences i'd had when i was younger
that seemed perfectly fine at the time
but weren't and i think i i i think this
has been important
um
but i think there's a real value for
everyone to think about
how
the
gains the
the changes and gains we've made
thanks to the metoo movement
how
that might impact traditional dating
strategies that involve
playing hard to get
because as you know pretty much every
popular dating book that's been written
over the past 30 years from the rules to
ignore the guy get the guy to why men
love [ __ ] that they all revolve
around a very complicated version of
playing hard to get
um and look i i wasn't dating in 1950
maybe playing hard to get
worked really really well back then and
i'm not saying it didn't
but i do believe that
nowadays and i actually think to a
certain extent even before the metoo
[Music]
movement
that playing hard to get has become
harder and harder and i mean think about
it this way that
if you're a guy at a party
and you're talking to a woman
and she seems disinterested
the correct response is not to assume
she's playing harder to get and wants
you to keep at it
the correct response is to leave her
alone
so if you have all these all these
dating book
gurus like the rules ladies
telling women and i think in one of
their books they actually say explicitly
um
uh
don't act so interested treat them like
a guy you don't like
well that's not going to work
nowadays and i'm not saying that to
defend the men
i'm saying this
to give an advantage to women because if
you as a single woman know
that guys are going to be more hesitant
and more reluctant to make the first
move
wow you have a huge built-in advantage
over other women who are sitting back
and waiting and waiting and waiting and
waiting for the guy they like to step up
because those women are playing by the
old rules and you're playing by the new
rules yeah i mean this is this is the
wild thing and
i really feel for young guys now that
are coming up i was on a night out not
long ago with one of my friends young
dude real successful guy big youtube
channel
university degree prestigious uni all
this stuff we were on a night out and i
was like oh there's a group of girls
over there why don't we go up and talk
to them i'm not bored of your crack i'm
bored of what you've got to say to me
like why don't we go go up and talk to
them and he he looked like i'd suggested
that we go and like pour their drink
over their head couldn't believe the
fact that i was suggesting that we go up
and speak to a girl no i would never i
would absolutely never what about all of
the metoo stuff and that was the first
time that i've ever seen
in real life
you know somebody that's close to me
that has similar values to myself that's
british
show the impact
the fear like complete terror and i
think that you you've quoted in the book
you say men used to worry about being
rejected now they're worried about being
labeled a predator
yeah that's a quote from a um
from brian howie who's who who
brian um
runs kind of a
a comedy
show or or kind of a a a
a dating town hall called the great love
debate and that was a quote from brian i
mean he does these kind of
dating town halls all across the u.s and
that was
that was his takeaway but i'm curious
your friend is he younger than you yeah
yeah he's 21 22. yeah yeah i i mean
what's
when i talk to both men and women that
age and that age group i'm always amazed
that there's like this i mean obviously
awkwardness and embarrassment like it's
never a good thing
but i feel like with the
the gen z crowd there is a next level
fear
of saying or doing the right thing
hypersensitivity and next like any kind
of awkwardness terrifies them
and
i
you know i
this doesn't bode well for dating
because dating really involves taking
chances but the good news for women is
that that you know my kind of go-to line
when i'm
talking about make your move on the
lecture circuit is that men like women
who like them
so
so when a woman takes a chance um
you know striking up a conversation with
a guy
the odds of her having blowback are far
less um
even though she's anxious and she's
worried and she feels the awkwardness i
i i think the odds of it being a
positive experience are better than for
your your friend or maybe it's all in
our heads but i think even if it is all
in our heads i i just think there are
these huge advantages for women to to
making the first move particularly if
they've already identified the guy they
like
this is the double-edged sword of um the
repercussions of me too into the dating
market i think that i i can sympathize
with the young guys who are lonely
would love to get a girlfriend but are
now terrified of being labeled a
predator
i think that one of the best fixes that
you could have would be for women to
kind of get a firmware update to their
operating system and realize that men
aren't playing by that old set of rules
anymore so the thing is that
women who aren't interested
and women who are interested are both
using the same strategies to respond to
men that approach them
and the men aren't
playing by that set of rules anymore if
you say no to a guy and he's a
respectable guy that's learned from me
too he's gonna think oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
hell like i'd better not i better not
push this i don't want to end up on the
the front page of reddit tomorrow and
right but if
if you're doing that in some sort of a
strategy to say well if i say no that's
kind of this sexy men love [ __ ]
strategy
thing i think that explains a lot about
why sort of chatting up and the circuits
of dating are
crumbling a bit
so i had an interesting conversation
with a woman named francesca hoagy who
is a kind of a high profile dating coach
matchmaker in los angeles and we were
talking about this very thing and here's
what i'm just going this i'm reading
from the book here
she says quote if a woman comes across
as indifferent men will take that as a
sign that she's not interested and will
move on it's getting to a point that if
the woman doesn't make the first move
the men are not going to this is not the
time to be demure at least not if you're
single and don't want to be single
and i think she's right i mean i'm
obviously i'm i'm generalizing and
they're going to be individual
situations that that play out
differently but i'm writing
you know like
the advice and make your move is macro
not micro and so i i can't i can't
account for every individual situation
but i i think what you just described is
spot on and that there has been this
culture shift and as a result women who
are willing
to make the first move or or at least
make it clear to men
that if the if they make that like just
to open the door wide enough so the men
know
that that it's safe to watch
an ambiguous signal yeah yeah so i i
mean i think like what happens as
somebody who like me who's writing
dating books and telling and sort of
pushing out the idea of women making the
first move
is that you get people
from the play hard to get crowd
who
they
they're quick to say oh terrible things
happen to women who make the first move
and they paint this picture that's kind
of like
cruella de vil chasing some poor guy
down the street and and that's their
image of what a woman making the first
move is
and to me
you know a first move by a woman can be
much more subtle i'll just give you an
example from the book there's a a woman
i interviewed um
very attractive really big personality
and you know some guys are a little
intimidated by women who are kind of the
life of the party
but she was at a at a super bowl party a
few years ago talking to a guy who she
really liked a lot
but he seemed nervous and wasn't sure
what to do so after like 45 minutes she
said to him so are you going to ask for
my number
now she didn't have to grab his ass or
like you know buy him a drink or
you know like
she'd have to do anything outrageous all
she had to do was make it clear to him
that that if
if he called her or he texted her
she would say yes and and that's
you know that's the
great thing from my perspective
when it comes to women making the first
move is that it doesn't have to be this
this giant display um this big event the
way it sometimes
the way men sometimes think it has to be
what was that melinda gates story
so the melinda gates so let me find it
up um
so the the
what's interesting you know i'm a big
fan of dating in the workplace and i and
you know that research shows that um
that couples who made it work
marry at a much higher rate than couples
who meet in any other way i think that
the marriage rate for workplace romances
is something like 30 percent which is
crazy high um and you don't really like
it
you don't need a phd in relationship
science to understand why workplace
relationships succeed i mean you already
know the person so
like
um
when i think about like the us version
of the office with uh you know with with
with jim and pam i mean
they they knew everything about each
other
long before they went out in an actual
date um so to me they were like oh you
know like halfway there or more before
the first date and i think this is the
advantage of dating people you you know
from work because you've seen them at
their best best and their worst somebody
who is
a good person in the workplace is going
to probably be a good person in the
relationship somebody who is selfish
or cruel in the workplace is going to be
selfish and cruel in a relationship but
obviously there are
there are challenges to um
with workplace dating particularly
nowadays and you alluded to this bill
and melinda gates story about how
they first started
dating um
and i i came across this podcast
interview that melinda gates gave
before they were divorced
but but she was talking about how um
how she and bill first started dating
and i guess they had met at some kind of
a manager's retreat and
uh like a month later he called her up
and he said and according to her he said
you know i was thinking maybe we could
go out if you give me your phone number
uh maybe two weeks from tonight that's
that's melinda's recollection
and melinda basically did what any
self-respecting 1990s woman would have
done she played hard to get
and she said
i said to him two weeks from tonight i
have no idea what i'm doing two weeks
from tonight and i said you're not
spontaneous enough for me
um
so
but he didn't bill didn't take no for an
answer and this is how she described it
um it was really sweet melinda recalled
he called back an hour later and said is
this spontaneous enough for you
and like when i heard her tell this
story my initial reaction was oh that's
a cute story because i grew up in an era
where that would have been
a cute story
that's not a cute story nowadays no
that's a that's a harassment lawsuit
waiting for you the next day the ceo
ringing
some assistant girl twice after she said
no
that is
yeah forbes forbes article in new york
times front page right
right yeah so so that that's the bill
and melinda gates story but
i
i have to say i i'm
i don't like these corporate rules that
that ban people from dating like if the
if the single ceo of mcdonald's
wants to be in a relationship with
another a single executive at mcdonald's
um
like i don't you know as long as there's
everything's above board and
i i don't see the harm in that um but i
guess it really depends what you
prioritize i mean if um if you put a
high priority on
on
on you know
marriage and family maybe you're going
to be more willing to take a risk with
an office romance than you would be
if you're just looking for a hookup
going back to
men and women's complete inability to
decipher what the other sex is asking
them to do didn't you look at how
useless men and women are at
distinguishing flirting
yeah no i mean i think i honestly think
this is
this is the fundamental problem because
i think particularly when you talk to
singles about making the first move
they'll say well
i was really clear i flirted with him
um
he obviously wasn't interested or maybe
she wasn't interested
um
the
the react you know that
i quote some science some research in
the book which shows that
i think it was
65 or 70 percent of flirtations are
completely lost on the person on the
receiving end
so
if you're a woman all those shoe dangles
and hair flips
he has no idea what you're
what's going on and i actually had this
funny conversation with my literary
agent and she was telling me oh my god
if i did a shoe dangle with my husband
he would have thought there was
something wrong with my foot
man here's the thing like
both men and women are bad at detecting
subtle advances but the environment that
we have in 2022 is increasingly neurotic
and people are less able to deal with
awkwardness there are more externalities
with being rebuffed you don't want to
end up as the butt of the joke in some
whatsapp group chat the next morning oh
you won't believe what this girl did
when or guy did when they came over so
it's almost like the risks are kind of
higher
in a way for people who do want to do
the approach and given the fact that
women culturally just aren't the sexual
protagonists
ever you know in history it's very rare
to have that being held up as some
archetype that everybody finds admirable
um
it doesn't surprise me and
all of this
wound up together explains it's one of
the many reasons why i think it's men
between the ages of 18 and 30
uh are reporting three times as many men
in the last 10 years are reporting no
sex within the last year
three times as many men between the ages
of 18 and 30. that's the age during
which most men would be
you know having sex being single perhaps
meeting new women going through multiple
relationships but yeah when you've got
no one can determine whether each other
is flirting and both sexes are so
terrified is to not flirt
that it doesn't happen it doesn't
surprise me
yes but from my perspective i'm writing
for women and to me
what you see as a negative i view as
this massive opportunity for single
women because
those who are willing to take a chance
just have this huge advantage um because
the marketplace so to speak um
is so different than it used to be well
you stand out right immediately and you
call this the suitor's advantage explain
that to me
so i have this
quip in the book in which i i say that
the that making the first move is the
only um
is the only dating strategy ever to be
awarded the nobel prize
and that's kind of true but but only
kind of um so there are a pair of
economists who won the nobel prize for
what they called a matching strategy
and matching for them yes it involves
relationships and marriage but it also
involves school admissions uh you know
job applications hiring things like that
any kind of matching
and what they found in their research is
that whichever party initiates the match
on average has a has a better outcome
than the one on the receiving end and
when you think about this from a dating
perspective it doesn't it makes perfect
sense because one of the advantages
that men
traditionally always had
is that at least
if they
were courageous enough
at least they had a chance with their
first choice woman
right so all they had to do was was ask
her out
um she could say no she could say yes
but at least you you got kind of a
definitive answer if if you're willing
to ask the question and it was
society said it was okay for you to you
know ask
susie out on the date because that's
what men do
but if you're susie
and you've always liked chris
um
but society says
you can't
you can't ask chris out on the date you
have to wait
for him to notice me
um
that's tricky because you know as i said
most people aren't good at communicating
romantic interests so ob so if you're if
your options are limited to the people
who make a first move with you
it's no surprise that the the outcomes
on average are going to be worse for
people
who are on the receiving end
of the matchmaking process rather than
those who initiate the match
that was borne out in a bunch of
experiments that you did right where you
got men and women to rank each other
based on what they wanted and then men
approached and women approached and
whichever sex was the one that decided
to be proactive
they on average all
of them ended up with a higher level
um rating
well i wish i could say it was my
research but this was actually part of
the research that won the nobel prize so
there's this whatever get take it take
it yeah yeah so i i have my nobel prize
in my closet back there um but yeah yeah
that was the gist of it that that
um
in this experiment the
the
the men were the ones who were allowed
to
propose marriage essentially and the men
on average ended up
with
higher ranked women on their list i'd
have to go through the math and you
probably don't want me to but but but
but the the gist of it is the outcome
was on average better for the for the
men in this experiment than it was for
the women and i think it's for all the
reasons
you know i i just discussed you say that
women in their 20s have an advantage at
finding a partner as well how come
so
i i might not put it that way but i do
think there's an advantage to starting
earlier um
that
you know the um
there's a lot of messaging that singles
i mean i would say women particularly
but i actually think it's it's men and
women as well that that you hear like
young educated people are told
that it's best to focus on your career
in your 20s and worry about
relationships or family
in your 30s
and
um
to me there are all sorts of problems
with this advice first if you're
actually worried about your career and
your earnings research actually shows
that that coupled people married people
earn more than single people so
the the whole kind of no you know the
the economic notion underlying this
advice is simply wrong
but
there's also kind of an assumption built
into this the dating will be just as
easy at 31
as it was at 23.
and for men for educated men it is it's
actually easier
but for women it gets harder and
i i always
like to compare this to the game of
musical chairs and chris did you ever
play musical chairs
as a kid i was a world champion yeah
right so
yeah okay so you know the basic idea
like you you know you start out with 25
players and 24 chairs and um in the
first round of musical chairs
in that in that case you have maybe a
four or five percent chance of losing in
the first round
by the last round of musical chairs when
there's two players in one chair
you have a 50 percent chance of losing
the game
so
the the more players and shares are
taken out of the game
the greater your odds of losing and this
is what you see playing out
um in dating
uh in with with educated people when
they you know
this is the situation women are facing
so
let's say you start out with a dating
pool
with 40
women and 30 men
um
once half of the women get married once
20 of the women get married to 20 of the
men
the the rate you know the the dating
pool becomes 20 women and 10 men
so we've gone from a four to three ratio
to a two to one ratio
once five more couples pair off it
becomes
15 women and five men
a three to one ratio
so
the point i'm always making look is if
you if you prioritize
marriage if you're a woman who
prioritizes marriage
there is there is no reason to to delay
um
you know either in terms of economics or
career as i said the
i i've yet to see any good evidence that
focusing on career not family your 20s
is beneficial but especially when it
comes to relationships because the
the the dating math
is just going to get harder um
as you get older although and you know
one of my
one of my arguments and make your move
is that there is an advantage for older
women to dip down age-wise um and i know
a bunch of couples where it's kind of a
a reverse age gap a woman you know five
six years older than the man um
and
by
by dipping down age-wise women can kind
of offset some of this well this i
wanted to explain for the people who
don't understand why this is obvious
the reason that it's more of a problem
for women dating at 31 than it is for
men dating at 31 is that women as they
get older on average are dating men that
are their age or older right whereas men
have a broader cross-section of women
that they can access who are younger
than them so it means that men basically
get a a broader dating pool as they get
older technically no that's absolutely
true but what i'm saying is that even if
people were only dating others their
exact age
if if 28 year olds were only dating 28
year olds you would still get this
musical cherish problem that i laid out
but but you're absolutely right that
that the problem becomes worse because
men
kind of have this
you know huge pool that they can older
men like the 31 year old man
can date
you know more broadly than the woman who
was who
through custom or experience or
socialization thinks she can only date
somebody
you know
a year or two or somebody older than
them yeah another another consideration
here in terms of attractiveness to men
is that one of the fundamental things
that men are typically attracted to is
youth signaled through fertility right
or fertility signaled through youth
which is you know
you can imagine a
girl who spends her 20s
going to college and maybe getting a
postgraduate degree as well and then you
know working her way up through a
company to be a high-powered executive
to then get to the stage that she's 31
and says right i'm now ready to find mr
wright and go after him and she doesn't
realize that mr wright very well may be
more attracted to the 24 year old
starbucks employee who is younger and
in his eyes fitter than this girl
many men not all men but on average men
don't value education levels as much as
women do they also don't value resource
levels as much as women do
yeah i i mean certainly that's i think
that's been the case in the past but you
know there was an interesting okay cupid
study which came out
probably six years ago in which they
found that um
that
that except on the margins except for
young women who are basically
supermodels
men didn't really perceive a big
attractiveness difference
between say
a 33 year old woman and a 23 year old
woman and that this
this notion that men all favor youth it
wasn't exactly borne out by the data yet
but but yeah if there's some
20 or 21 year old model or starlet yes
you know that's that's interesting yeah
that's that would that runs pretty
counter to
to what i would have expected and what
i've seen in a
in a
fair bit of data but again another one
of the another one of the things to
consider here is that the men as they
get older
they are accumulating more status and
resources which allows them to slowly
rise up through their own dominance
hierarchy the competence hierarchy as
well so the men that are 21 who might
want to try and date the 25 year old
woman are competing with the men who are
31 who have 10 more years of
experience and charisma and status and
resources and
the understanding of what shirt goes
with what pants and stuff like that so
it makes it a more difficult game you
know the
the um
the couple who i feature in the chapter
on these reverse age gaps on on women
dating younger men um
yeah i think when they got together
she was 32 when he was maybe
27 or 26. and
one of the things that they talked about
was that
when he was dating people his own age
he's a very competitive person and he
was frequently dating women who were in
his own field he's a kind of a
photographer
designer arts type and
he would get really pissed off and
jealous
any time his girlfriends seem to be
doing a little bit better better than
them career-wise
and one of the things that they talked
about is that this kind of
competitiveness
was really a non-issue for them because
he understood that she was
five years ahead of him career-wise
and it actually made the relationship
easier because she could be really
supportive of him and he could take her
advice and there wasn't this kind of
friction of two
like successful people of the same age
you know two two doctors two lawyers um
who are married to each other and are
anxious about
about
you know
about
the status of their career
um and i do think that these these
reverse age age gaps can kind of
address this problem that you hear women
talk about all the time about about
having a hard time finding men who are
comfortable with their success
yeah i think you know if you if you date
a younger man i think that's going to be
easier
yeah i i wonder it would be interesting
to see some more research on this i
think that it's going to be difficult
for women to fundamentally be attracted
to men that are younger than them um so
i've got a
little bit of research here from vincent
haranam if you're familiar with him guy
right now right
data scientist very interested in the
dating market you'd love his stuff i'll
send you some articles once we're done
um so this is just a bunch of stuff that
you might not have been familiar with
all fairly recent research so i'm just
going to do run through some of this and
i'll get your thoughts afterwards let us
consider height according to one study
women were most satisfied when their
partner was 21 centimeters taller this
was corroborated by other studies which
found which 49 of women prefer dating
taller men and that the shortest man a
woman would date is five feet nine
inches on average a 1939 study found
that american women rated good financial
prospects twice as highly as males when
gauging the value of a marriage partner
this finding was replicated in studies
conducted in 1956 and 1967 moreover
david buss attempted to replicate these
studies surveyed 1 491 americans across
four states in the mid 1980s once again
women valued good financial prospects in
a mate roughly twice as much as a male
did this gender difference has not
changed in fact a 2014 pew research
survey reported that 78 of unmarried
women placed a high premium on finding a
spouse for this steady job only 48 of
men shared this view in the study the
attributes valued in a marriage partner
psychologist douglas kenrick asked men
and women to indicate the minimum
percentiles of each attribute that they
would find acceptable when it came to
earning capacity women indicated that
they preferred a man who earned more
than 70 of all other men in contrast men
desired a mate that earned more than 40
of all other women basically it just
bears out this is the sort of resources
and state this hypergamy thing that
seems to be borne out in the data but it
seemed like when you looked at stuff to
make your move that you
you found a little bit of a different
narrative coming through for women
so yeah i mean i i i do think men are
competitive by nature and this is why i
think the reverse age gap
like when you talk about a man wanting
to be with a woman who earns less
um
i
i understand where that comes from
i don't think he's going to feel the
same way
if it's like this couple i interview
from my book where he's 27 and she's 32
and she's supposed to be making more
than him because because because of the
age gap and the other thing i'll point
out is if you look at
the same pure research data
yes it shows that men are more like that
that married men earn more than their
their partners but if you look at the
trend
the um
the percentage of women who are primary
breadwinners in their family has been
steadily increasing
there's actually
a higher percentage of women
married to lesser educated men in the
u.s than men
married to lesser educated women is that
not only in college graduates though is
that not only no this is everything so
this notion of the doctor who's married
to the nurse
or
or the investment banker married to the
cocktail waitress
this is this is not borne out by reality
this is kind of this this stereotype
that's out there and actually men are
are choosier about women's education
than women are according to the data
given the fact that there's more women
graduating university
this makes sense though you wouldn't
need to you would need to normalize for
the fact that there's far more women
coming out of college
in order to
ameliorate that
you're right but but there is this
notion out there that
mental men will marry anybody and the
women are too choosy and the data does
not bear that out the data shows that
when it comes to education at least men
are more choosy about education than
women are okay which i know doesn't it
doesn't fit the stereotype but it's true
and then going back to david buss um i
met him at a conference a bunch of years
ago and we were talking about some of
this stuff and he remained
he expressed with great certainty
that
that the
that you know if you have
40 50 percent more women than men
graduating graduating from college
that there will always be
like this large proportion of women who
never get married and that's just the
way it's going it is and that's the way
it's going to be and that those women
will never ever ever
stoop so low as to marry an electrician
or a plumber or anything like that and i
just don't i don't agree with that it's
not the kind of world i want to live in
i i see so many examples of what i call
mixed collar relationships in the world
you've also said that in your research
there's been an increase in assortative
mating
yeah there has and i think
you know like sometimes i i would have
interviewers ask me
well
why wasn't this an issue in 1940
when there were more men than women
attending college and my answer to that
is well the college thing wasn't as
important back then and people weren't
making decisions about
about marriage as much based on whether
or not somebody went to college that
would would that not also fit the
hypergamous women are prepared to date
up and across if men are outperforming
women then
no yeah you have a point but i i just
if you look at some of the more recent
data particularly from pure research you
do see
the beginnings of a trend and i hope
it's a longer term trend of people being
more open-minded when it comes to
whom they date and eventually marry and
actually there was a
a
a brilliant reporter um
for the um
for the guardian who interviewed me
about about datanomics
um and
she wrote a story about the book and she
was telling me that she had been
in a long-term relationship with a bus
driver and they were they were very
happy together um and so for her and she
had you know kind of successful friends
who you know some of them were dating
highly educated men some weren't and it
wasn't quite the same taboo in terms of
dating somebody
lesser educated at least among her
friend group as it might have been for
her for her parents generation
and so my hope is we're moving towards a
world
where
the
gentlemanly electrician is just as good
a catch as the
[ __ ] investment banker
how easy do you think it is for women to
hack that hypergamous nature
i i mean to me i think a lot of this
goes back to how we meet um
because when you talk about things like
i i want a guy who's
six feet tall or makes
more than 127 000 a year whenever it is
in pounds
or
is this age or
this amount of hair
it really sounds more like picking
options on a car than it does
finding
your true love and to me all of this
goes back
to the cesspool that is online dating
like if you if you met a guy who was
five foot nine at a part not you but a
woman met a guy who's five foot nine at
a party and brilliant and funny and
handsome
she's not gonna notice these five foot
nine i mean i i i'm six feet tall my
wife is five two
everybody looks tall to my wife like
whether i was five eight or six two she
would think i'm tall
but when it comes down to putting a
number
on a screening function on a dating app
people start treating
dating like shopping
and there's this really unhealthy
consumerist
mindset that i think has infected the
world of of of of romance in which
you know everything is shopping
and if you don't like it you can return
it
and
it's all about finding the best deal and
you can just punch in some
some metrics
on a on a dating app and out will pop up
you know your prince charming and
a i don't think that's true and b and i
think this is really the important thing
that
the stories of how we meet are important
like you you could meet somebody on a
dating app
and not hit it off but meet the but the
the very same person you could be
in a
you know a tennis club or a jar or
running group with and get to know him
or work with them and it would be a
totally different connection
than
chatting with them on a dating app and
meeting up at sushi palace at 7 p.m
and the the and
all the research shows that the stories
of how we meet are really important
and people become much more invested in
in
kind of
stories that involve meeting in the real
world meeting in the wild
um
it's also much um particularly for women
um
i i don't think men fully appreciate
the
the safety concerns related to online
dating i mean i was on a
a podcast with a um a male author a a
few months ago and he was recently
divorced and he was telling me the story
about um going out in his first online
first date and he discovered that the
woman who we met at the coffee shop knew
everything about him because she had
been googling it
and he thought this was weird and creepy
and i was like that's not weird and
creepy that that is the way
that's what every woman
i know is doing and it's because if you
look at the at the surveys on this the
majority of women consider online dating
to be unsafe
55 percent have been threatened with
physical violence while using dating
apps
so obviously they are going to
protect themselves
by doing this research they're also
going to tell their roommate or their
mom and their sister
i'm going to be at sushi palace at 7 if
you don't hear from me by
10
get worried
but the problem with this beyond the
obvious is that if you enter if you go
into a first date with this level of
anxiety and and fear
it it's not going to lead to falling in
like or falling in love because
you're
you're on guard to make sure that robert
the handsome money manager isn't
actually billy bob the married ex-con
whereas if you were dating somebody you
actually know and actually like from the
real world
it might not be a great first date but
there's so much more comfort involved
in that first aid experience and you can
just kind of relax and get to know the
person and it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be like an interview
in which you're trying to poke holes in
their story
based on what i have seen from your
advice in make your move
it seems to me that it's
mostly um competitive edges that
specifically women
would be able to find by adjusting their
dating strategies so the first one would
be don't be afraid of making the first
move of approaching the man being the
protagonist in the uh flirting
relationship right of
suggesting that he get your number or
asking for his number or whatever and
then the second one being more like a
modality change that look at the other
places that you can try and find people
that you would want to date rather than
online dating so yeah both of these
no matter whether they run counter to
culture or expected norms or whatever
they're just opportunities as far as i
can see it all that they are are
competitive edges that women can find
incredibly easily by deciding that
they're going to do something different
to what the rest of the market does so
i've got this stat that i always throw
around about podcasts so
ninety percent of podcasts don't make
you past episode three
and of the ten percent that do
90 don't make it past episode 20. so by
making it to episode 21 you were in the
top 1
of all podcasters ever in history right
i love that it's awesome great start
that's consistency consistency is the
most
underrated and
rare
internet creator
value that that exists as far as i can
see very very few people do a hard thing
at the same time every single week for
an extended period of time
similarly to this
if most women aren't doing a thing
however you know that there's a
competitive edge by doing that thing
we've already seen it's borne out in the
data
if you decide to be the protagonist when
approaching somebody
on average you will end up with a
preferable partner to if you wait for
those people to come back around right
nobel prize [ __ ]
the other side of that is that
i i don't think that online dating is a
fantastically fun experience for most
men most men are kind of wistfully sat
on their own not really getting matches
from women and most women are getting
matches from men that they're not
tremendously interested in and
potentially fearful of even if they do
manage to get a match and then go on a
date and then it's this sort of weird
performative thing where you're
fact-checking against the profile for
all of it so both of these are just
competitive edges but the same way as
the consistency thing being a real easy
hack to be able to get through
podcasting what are most podcasters not
doing which is still a good outcome okay
consistency what are most women not
doing in the dating market which is a
good outcome they're not approaching and
they're relying too heavily on online
dating
yeah i that
that's a a great summary i mean the only
thing i'd add to the online dating thing
is that to me it goes beyond
you know
coming up with a little edge or a little
strategic advantage i mean there is a
fundamental efficacy problem with online
dating there was a study out of the uk a
few months ago which found that the
divorce rate for couples to meet on
dating apps is six times higher than it
is uh for couples who meet in the real
world it was a stanford university study
which um
claimed in the body of the report that
there was not much difference in the
one-year breakup rates of couples who
meet online
versus the real world
but if you dig into the appendix and you
look at the actual data the one-year
breakup rate for couples who meet online
in this study was 16 percent for couples
to meet through friends and family it
was eight percent for couples of meet at
work it was six percent and for couples
who meet in a house of worship it was
one person one percent yeah i quoted
this
so it's not it's not just
that
are the women are relying too heavily on
one thing and the need to diversify
their strategy i actually think there is
something fundamentally awful about
online dating that is going to lead to
um
uh
less i mean i believe it or not i'm a
romantic at heart
and
despite the incredibly autistic view of
dating and yes yeah
i want i want people to be happy and i
want people to find true love
and i just think it's really hard to
find true love
when you're
going out with complete strangers
on a dating app and i i'm always like
comparing it to friendship
i don't know if you've heard me with
this this stick before but but chris do
you have a best friend i do
are you best mate i guess yeah yeah yeah
okay okay how did you meet your best
mate
through another one
but in the real world yeah yeah yeah by
referral in in the real world
and and you you have real world
experiences together uh many yes right
can you imagine going on bestmate.com
and finding a connection like the one
you have with your best mate not gonna
happen no i mean i mean i mean obviously
it's like human beings evolve to social
animals we connect through shared
real world experience like like all
primates do so i'm
yes i i believe you can get an edge by
logging off the dating apps but to me it
goes beyond that i i worry about the
state of romance and about the
about people's ability to find true love
if they're relying on dating complete
strangers
you know i i gave a
talk at ron's college which is a small
liberal arts school in florida a few
months back and we were talking about
this online dating stuff and um
at the end of the class a woman raised
her hand and said okay i get it nobody
likes online dating it sucks but
how the heck am i supposed to meet
somebody if not through an app
so i took a chance and i asked a
question and the question was
how many of you
have somebody you already know and like
from the real world whom you've ever
wondered about dating
there were 40 kids in this group 40
hands went up
now look i i know that if it was a group
of 48 year olds it might have been a
different
different result than
pulling a group of 22 year olds or 21
year olds but i do ask this question a
lot and what i find is that the majority
of singles
already have identified somebody they
already know and like from the real
world who they've been interested in
dating
so my view is you're already probably a
third of the way maybe even halfway
there
with this person
and
like
if all that's holding you back is some
fear of ruining the friendship
don't worry about that like you know
take a chance embrace the awkwardness
take a chance with the person who you
know you have a connection with as
opposed to going out on 100 blind dates
with
strangers from the internet
one of the last things that me and you
both agree on i think is um a suggestion
that women should uncheck the college
box
when it comes to looking at who they're
trying to date and i think that you're
right um online dating has facilitated a
much more
uh like technocratic
bureaucratic predisposed transactional
way of looking at okay so what are the
things that i want like it's you know
options on a car optional extra i need
the air conditioning in the leather
seats right or whatever right like
it's not the way that things work and it
doesn't account for in real life changes
i've got friends who are five foot eight
five foot nine guys that aren't into the
gym they're not in like ridiculous shape
or anything but they crush on nights out
because they're charming and they're
funny and they're outgoing and and they
can hold eye contact and they're great
and you think well
that person on an app can't get any of
those
which are the characteristics that we
value the most overall so what
dating apps have optimized for are
people selecting some of the most
arbitrary features of a mate that they
can
whilst
uh omitting all of the ones that we
probably genuinely do care about right
however exactly however i think that one
of the challenges i was listening to you
on a podcast with um a couple of girls
it was a dating podcast and you were
talking about like unchecking the
college box and one of the girls said
well i've got a postgraduate degree and
you know even if the guy that i was
speaking to had like a a community
college degree i might feel a little bit
i don't really know we're going to be
able to have this connection so i do
think that there is work to be done
to try and undo
some of the
predispositions that girls have around
who they're going to be attracted to
there is a huge pool of sexless men this
is where mgtow and the incel
sort of black pill forums have come out
of yes they're at the very very tail end
of this but still there is a big big
pool of men who we haven't really spoken
about today on the podcast this is
mostly kind of college for college or
college for professional as you start to
drop a little bit further down that
hierarchy for men you know there is a
huge huge pool of guys down there that
would make absolutely fantastic partners
i'm sure but might not hit those
quantifiable metrics of success so i
definitely think that women opening up
that dating pool a little bit more is a
a good thing for them to do yeah
and like the guys i'm thinking about
aren't necessarily the the young incel
guys i mean i um
for years and years i i coach travel
baseball um and the
you know even though i live in kind of a
leafy suburb the travel baseball crowd
tends to be the parents tend to be a
little more blue-collar so it's a lot of
policemen and electricians and
guys who run landscaping businesses
things like that and
um
they are awesome guys like you know
you know they're real men not like me
like
but
you know um and i keep thinking to
myself and also like a lot of them
earn a shitload of money um you know
doing
uh construction
all sort of not running businesses
i always like to joke that my plumber um
i guarantee earns more than me because
every time he comes here late at night
he's driving an audi so so so the so
these guys not only are they really good
guys um they probably are some a lot of
them probably earn more than you think
and
i i i suspect
you know i i think there are a lot of
women who maybe think they want
you know the the smart lawyer or banker
but if you put them in the room with
kind of the um
the manly man who can like fix your
dishwasher or change your tire right or
even i can change the tire but but you
know what like that
some of these guys um they might
actually feel more of a connection with
than the university educated blokes that
they've been
having trouble with
john berger ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do where should they go
um so my website is johnberger.com
um i'm off of twitter these days but uh
you can find me on instagram i'm i think
i'm john underscore burger one on
instagram
um also if you have a book club and you
want to read one of my books um i've
partnered with obviously you can read it
if you want but i partnered with um with
a uh an author platform called
bookyaya.com
and basically it's a platform that that
connects um
book clubs with authors who maybe could
do remote events um
you know with the with book clubs so you
can find me on book yaya as well cool i
i really appreciate reading um a lot of
the dynamics that i'm familiar with and
i've been learning about and are very
interested in but from a female
perspective i think that it's something
that i hadn't considered and the more
that i think about the experience that
women have with dating the more that i
can understand where we're at so i
appreciate the work that you do john i
look forward to whatever it is that you
write next i think it'll be really
really cool
thanks chris i appreciate you having me
on what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you